prêt à tester tester c'est le début de
l'opération de dépistage massif
pendant deux jours les résidents
symptomatiques sont invités à se
présenter son rendez vous à la clinique
mobile installée dans le quartier
saint-michel foyers d'éclosion important
la situation est déjà la fac c'est sûr
que plus on dépiste plus on trouve une
façon de mieux comprendre
l'épidémiologie de l'environnement un
environnement similaire à celui de
montréal nord
l'arrondissement le plus touché par
l'épidémie ce michel c'est un quartier
très diversifié donc on parle d'une
population autour de 55 mille personnes
à peu près donc beaucoup moins que
montréal la mer et en eaux calmes en
termes de proportion
nous sommes beaucoup plus high tech
clairement nous sommes très préoccupés
parce qu'on a beaucoup de personnes
âgées
on a beaucoup de travailleurs qui sont
des travailleurs de première ligne des
travailleurs au niveau de la santé faire
le test ça prend entre 5 à 7 minutes et
le fioul de l'est de montréal estime
pouvoir en faire entre 100 et 150 par
jour
ou bien la balle si si on utilise les
tests avec écouvillon québec comme
d'autres provinces comptait aussi miser
éventuellement sur les tests rapides de
salive que développe l'entreprise
ontarienne ce partant mais voilà que
santé canada restreint l'utilisation de
ce test uniquement à la recherche for
war le test s'est avéré moins efficace
en clinique avec des patients qu'en
laboratoire explique l'administratrice
en chef de la santé publique du canada
ce qui ne devrait toutefois pas avoir
d'impact sur la capacité de dépistage
des provinces ajoute-t-elle
vendredi encore le docteur arruda jouer
de prudence du fonds par tino plein e
comme d'autres mais actuellement ce
qu'on va faire actuellement utilisés
c'est pas ça du tout là quand on parle
d'augmenter à 14000 pour pourvoir du
prochain on est sur la même méthodologie
reste que plusieurs provinces notamment
l'alberta l'ontario et le québec avaient
déjà commandes
des millions de tests pour des millions
de dollars à cette entreprise
issigeac aude richard blu ray du canada
montréal jacques audrey à long terme on
pourrait s'en tire tout de même l'impact
de cette interdiction d'utilisation
étaient ceux spartan sur les capacités
des provinces a testé massivement la
population
oui évidemment on n'a pas de boule de
cristal mais les commandes elles étaient
quand même importante l'autre l'ontario
par exemple s'attendait à recevoir près
de 1 million de tests pour une somme de
70 millions $ le québec en avait
commandé 200 milles la commande elle
était conditionnelle à l'homologation de
santé canada mais elle devait être livré
à la fin mai donc oui pas d'impact dans
les prochaines semaines mais dans les
scénarios à long terme
évidemment ce dossier là va revenir
surtout parce que pascal les experts le
disent et l'heureux 10
la clé d'un déconfinement réussi c'est
la capacité accrue de dépistage oui
merci beaucoup jacques audrey pas voir